[Musik]
etwas klappt netz bekommen beim an video
heute das geht ich hoffe euch gibt einen
gut so wie das jetzt drei tage nicht kam
ist kein ding jetzt gibt weiter morgen
kommt dieses video freitag aber muss ich
gar nicht sagen die besten reiter nicht
ganz so gut überlegt wie immer und zwar
kriege ich technisch sehr oft bei ins
netz hat einfach die bilder geschickt
oder leute sagen hey der typ- oder was
mädchen das war kam auch schon mal vor
aber bereits nicht weiter darauf
eingehen soll ein als wird von wegen
eher der typ der sieht wirklich genauso
oft wie du und ich finde was immer sehr
interessant weil da sieht man mal wie
andere leute ein weil wenn ich mir dann
zum teil die bilder anschaue denke ich
mir bin ich schließlich so hässlich aber
das ein oder andere ist schon dabei wo
ich dachte alter kranker liegt mir echt
so ähnlich und deswegen habe ich mich
hingesetzt und habe gedacht da mal diese
ganzen nachrichten raus
das problem war meine in studies ist das
ist eines von so weit unten ich habe das
gar nicht mehr gefunden ich habe zwei
sachen gefunden und hab euch dann
aufgefallen fenster bauleute schickte
noch mal weitere zu weitere leute die so
ähnlich aussehen wie ich und das habt
ihr ganz weiß ich gemacht deswegen
schauen wir etwas zusammen an und ihr
werdet sehen wie kratzer zum teil ist
mal einer dabei der süd wirklich eins zu
eins auf die ich für mich wenn ich das
wieder gefällt obwohl ist noch gar
nichts sagen können tropfen auch nach
oben lassen
vielleicht sind sie drin so wir fangen
mit dem ersten bild und war hat mir
jemand davon effekt geschickt der typ
wieder einfach eins zu eins aus wie du
das ist super ich habe das bild ein
kunst- und dachte so jäger schütze mich
verraten wo sieht eher so aus wie ich
sage mir das bitte hab ich lange haare
nein hab ich mich habe ich ein bad ein
habe ich auch nicht hab ich dann roten
mund
ich weiß wenn ich mir anschaue die
augenfarbe und die augenbrauen und
vielleicht die nase ist ein bisschen
gleich aber das war oder als mein mund
irgendwie vollrodt grad ein mündlich
grad voll roter klecks der durchblutet
hier durch die massen
also ich finde wirklich höchstens 10%
ähnlichkeit wenn ihr mehr ähnlichkeit
wie das würde interessieren
kommentare und wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten und war schreibt mir die
christina er war von hinten aus wie du
und wenn ich mir das bild mal genauer
anschauen was ich erst mal sagen okay
die drei verstehen denn vielleicht 314
vielleicht auch 15 keine ahnung aber der
typ mit den blonden haaren
der sieht echt ein bisschen auf schießt
du vielleicht ja auch wenn er was seine
jünger ist ich zeige euch mal kurz ins
bild ich hoffe ich finde das noch also
an meinen einen doppelgänger von hinten
zumindest kann ich das bild nicht
einbilden ganz einfach ich hab dich mehr
keine des bildes weg niemand keine
fanpage hat reported was fällt euch ein
deswegen stelle ich mich einfach so vor
händlern gewisse ähnlichkeit wäre auf
jeden fall heute machen wir weiter mit
dem nächsten wie aus dem gesicht
geschnitten
auf jeden fall wie aus dem gesicht
geschnitten 100 prozent ähnlich also das
war richtig von bild der überraschte das
ist echt nah an meinem auto
da habe ich wie ich dachte das ist ein
richtig richtig richtig glatt verdoppelt
ich weiß nicht wer die person ist habe
ich noch nie gesehen wurde jakob
bedeuten amerikanerinnen keine ahnung
schaut euch einfach diese ähnlichkeit an
das ist doch verblüffend war natürlich
ein start komme zu nächsten könnte
deinen doppel her sein wo ich mir auch
gedacht habe acom vor den han herr
vielleicht ihr vater oder ich meine der
26 27 und echter nähren jedoch aus
dieser junge am 2
denn hier kann man das eventuell sagen
wobei ist das auch nicht so schön die
sind ja wissen gelockt von ihm und bei
mir halt nicht aber er vom gesicht hat
ein erstes sieht toll aus wenn sie gar
nicht aus sich und ich feiere sein auto
nicht ich hab mich dann eben irgendwie
ich habe da nicht für die ewigkeit
gewesen so wahrscheinlich dass irgendwer
den wohl jeder kennt und ich hab ich
noch nie gesehen mehr beschreibt hatte
auch meine kommentare ob der ähnlich auf
dem weg aber jetzt kommen wir zu meinen
absoluten favoriten durch die recht
dachte alter
die haare sind fand ich blond aber wenn
die haare blond das könnte uns sportlich
sein also heidfeld korrigieren und zwar
steigt die hanna er sieht genauso aus
wie du und darauf kann ich sagen ich
habe zwar keine blauen haare
aber der wird mir echt verdammt ähnlich
und ich hab mir gerade ich stelle
einfach mal ein bisschen nach und guckt
so wie er
und dann schauen wir mal ob das wirklich
gleich aussieht dass muss also leute der
eu dürfte in die richtung und ich
verwirrt es gibt einfach mal kurz augen
nachbestellen einen die richtung und
dann könnt ihr kann man ja mal mache ich
mein bild kurth und macht dazu
nebeneinander und schreibt immer in die
kommentare
ob ich das auch so wichtig ich war echt
fasziniert davon
[Musik]
als basisjahr für den video mit
interessieren
das aus dass der letzte mir wirklich
extrem ähnlich dann hat man da was sie
extrem ähnlich sieht danach noch nach
oben da ansonsten wollte ich noch
schnell sagen bayern shopping.com werden
wir zu jeder bestellung ein euro an den
guten zweck gespendet das haben wir
jetzt noch eingeführt einfach essen
wegen der vielen bestellungen einkommen
und davon dann immer euro abzugeben ist
finde ich cool beispiel gesagt haben
wenn etwas gefällt dann könnt ihr euch
das gern kaufen und davon geht dann halt
immer in euro auch in den guten zweck
wir sehen uns dann am morgigen
donnerstag wieder anfangs nur hard rain
folgendes instagram und netzer